welcome to the FDOT on Yahoo Sports
Peter King Mike Florio some of the
biggest stories happening right now in
the NFL and in New England the Patriots
are nine and one but it's driven by
their defense and their special team
their offense not as good as it's been
in past years and and by a large margin
Tom Brady has not been happy when he's
spoken about it recently
Peter how worried should the Patriots be
about Brady being upset about Brady
possibly seeing his skills diminished
and all the money about Brady
potentially leaving after the season
when his contract expires and there's
nothing they can do to force him to stay
you know Mike I think this is I think
with Bill Belichick and with the whole
organization this is about the next 10
weeks this is not about what is gonna
happen in the offseason 10 or 11 weeks
whatever it is this has to be about
trying to get this offense right so they
can make one more run because I'm sure
there's a lot of people inside the
Patriots who understand and believe that
this is the swansong for Tom Brady in
New England whether it is or not we
don't know yet but I do want to make one
point about Brady and about this de
munition of skills that everybody says
he has so from last year to this year
and last year they weren't an
intergalactic offense but from last year
to this year they've lost three of their
what I would consider their top four
receivers you know in Josh Gordon Rob
Gronkowski Chris Hogan that's 122
catches and nine touchdowns gone
vanished and not replaced so they're
trying to make do with a lot lesser guys
there and what that is doing speaking of
comparisons the running game in 2018
versus 19 I mean it's a shell of itself
this year average per carry last year
4.3 average per carry right now at this
point three point three if you don't
have anything downfield that is going to
scare a defensive coordinator then
they're going to jam up the box and say
hey Tom beat us with these now
existent threats downfield yeah I agree
with you there and Peter the other thing
too when it's time to play
single-elimination football Tom Brady
has been there and done that so many
times he doesn't get nervous he doesn't
get flustered he thrives on those
moments especially because he knows he's
only got so many of them left and he is
going to rise to that occasion like he
did against the chiefs down the stretch
in the AFC championship game when it
appeared that the Patriots are going to
lose in Kansas City was heading to the
Super Bowl for a rematch against the
Rams so Brady's value to that team and
you said it they're gonna focus only on
what's in front of them he will step up
at some point make a big play throwing
it to whoever is available to him
helping the team score points or sustain
a drive or whatever it is in that moment
that requires him to perform in a clutch
and he will he's done it he'll do it
again
and that may be why the folks at the
West Gate Superbook have the Patriots as
the favorite to win the Super Bowl even
though right now most people would say
the Ravens are more likely than New
England to get it done Mike you know at
the end of the day Bill Belichick is
always about and to be cliche whatever
today is November 20th he's always more
about January 20th and november 20th and
so that's what they're really concerned
about and the biggest question of all
that you have to ask yourself maybe the
games in Baltimore maybe the games in
Foxborough I don't know but who is going
to beat Tom Brady in a potential AFC
Championship game probably in Foxborough
but maybe in Baltimore I think it's the
Patriots are still gonna be a very tough
out I agree with you completely and Tom
Brady will pursue championship number
seven and then if they get it or if they
don't who knows what comes next but I
agree with what you said Peter the
Patriots don't care about any of what
comes next until they finish the season
what comes next is the cowboys and then
after that the next opponent and the
next one and the next one and they
compartmentalize like no one else that's
it for this edition of pft ot on Yahoo
Sports check us out all season long for
more videos addressing the top store
in the National Football League
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports